lo speciale di domani sabato 22 lo
speciale dei 5 milioni di iscritti e il
video più bello del mondo dell'universo
esistente se non lo guardate non vivere
se non lo guardate domani poi non esiste
più non so come dirlo tutte le robe
importantissimi che avete da fare domani
vanno prese buttate nel cesso tutte
nulla è più importante della vostra vita
che lo speciale di domani e la svolta
per la vostra esistenza non potete
perdere ve lo dovete guardarlo
assolutamente domani sabato 22 dicembre
a mezzogiorno uscirà allo speciale 5
milioni d'iscritti segnatevelo tatuate
melo addosso su video mi lascio al video
bella tutti ragazzi comete sono di
chiesanuova dj oggi siamo su scritto
appunto io non so se ve lo ricordate
quel gioco dove devi indovinare che cosa
disegnano gli altri che cosa disegno io
devo indovinarlo gli altri mi spiego
come una capra morta spero che sappia
disegnare meglio di quanto mi spiego lo
chiamo monociglio o round bts armi.il
che hip hop cia colonizzate pop pop
red botton dove indovinare che cos'è
quella roba lì in inglese diventato
aspetta che devo capire la b chiesa già
indovinato mannaia va irene faccio
vedere ma perciò i baffi come possibile
tre parole tre lettere volevo dire
niente bad quello era un letto come bts
armi featuring awards sta scegliendo una
parola va il palloncino got the art e al
pizza fantasma agosto quasi primo quasi
più non il primo o al secondo una
tabella con bulow indovini per far
comunque sì bravo a disegnare i
complimenti tranche hip hop e l'altro lo
fai anche pratica di disegno lo apprezzo
di isis occhiute rider dance carey beh
effettivamente irene using a world irene
lo saprai l'inglese sì perché mi sta
battendo già lo sapevo che avrebbe
scritto il nome di quello del bts lo
sapevo e disney disney disney non ci
credo mi chiami sembravano in topolino
che i muse mamma mia
what a player sembra un sacco topolino
sia stata brava irene complimenti se
stai guardando questo video sposami
topolino non è nero comunque mai forgot
o d'asilo klein like ciccio gamer
le do una mano ma comunque brava irene
sei stata molto brava seconda cinque
lettere facciamo stick una person
persone persona 5 beyond blonde è il
ciuffo ciuffo eyong va a cagare però
semplicissimo era veramente easy solo la
bibla quella della bts ne ha indovinato
non ho capito niente che cali il pds che
peccato è uscito e non sei tranquillo
zio ancora mai visto me per kharja un me
poi ne riparliamo newspaper sparato
inizia a sparare frasi parole a caso con
quelle lettere lite parking per
l'indovinata impossibile gate
hai un camino fireplace signori prima di
irene grazie mille
sono stato molto bravo non sai di
segnare poi inizia a scrivere come
sempre ho superato irene ma parole
facili ci sono perché aumentato un sacco
la difficoltà rispetto all'altra volta
sauron sturalavandini così stura
lavandini e ma non vali non solo inglese
lega a sapere l'inglese aver indovinato
molto prima molto prima di aver
indovinato i fatti non c'è gara secondo
me con tutti se non con irene che
italiano portò il es
e che cosa dovrebbe essere se non per
quello abbiamo anche scritto da irene
brava irene complimenti o superata
ancora hanno superato irene parcak a
quanta difficile dai forse con questa se
la indovino prima di lei questa qua è un
c'è un cerchio lo sta facendo sta
sbattendo la testa sulla tastiera sta
tipa collar
dog cane kolar vuol dire kolar cosa vuol
dire ma cos'è che continua a cercare lì
a white ma a cagare era era lo sfondo
white
io pensavo fosse un cerchio porca vacca
white white e irene troppo tardi forse
con superata forza da lasciamo fuori con
che è possibile siamo a piedi pari al di
sotto come la parola è bric di un
mattone o bene ma c'è un aspetto che
faccio il mattone è meglio fare altri
però aspetta e devo fare un muro vorrei
farlo velocemente ma non posso contempo
non sono donald trump uno la indovinato
solo una persona per adesso aspetta no
ma ho sbagliato piaciuto tutto quel che
era giusto questo qua dai questo qua è
facilissimo e semplice l'ho fatto prima
era uno solo uno solo dai bric facile
ragazzi sporco le mani per ora troppo
che sfiga era semplice a derivati
ridarlo vabbè importante che ho superato
irene perché l'ho superata mi ha dato
punti
se anche io dicevo a dopo le
interrogazioni quando ho già preso due
era carlo magno quello che giocare alle
slot machine circo red botton japan flag
japan flag pomodoro su come si c'è
pomodori che thor tomato che è sta roba
qua spiega cos'è star cos'è logan po
fruit frutto era un frutto quella è una
banana quella è una banana ma una banana
schiacciata da un camion immagino no
perché cosa ah ecco non avevo sai che
non sai disegna parco lemonia faccio
schifo io mamma mia sono io sono un
secondo suo terzo normale slide pizza
pizza slice torta torta come ho
indovinato cos'è cos'è un cinese una
torta cinese torta cinese
raga non capisco giuro solo i renan
dominato
non ho idea di cosa sia giuro
complimenti si è molto bravo a disegnare
la brava per aver fatto illuminare
l'unica persona che non doveva
indovinare i complimenti birthday
compleanno quale era un cinese
i reni se n'è andata trovato ha capito
che io sono più forte quindi sono
contento fly penn pene ma come
indovinato a forbici cut porco demonio
porco indovinato dopo però sono stato
molto bravo devo battere qwerty adesso
sono secondo sono passato secondo perché
irene se n'è andata quindi devo
assolutamente battere qwerty e sono
davanti a quella dei bts bravo mi fa
scassare la gente che che disegna da
cani e poi fa la freccetta per indicare
mi fa scassare perché fai schifo il
disegno cosa cos'hai in di chi non è
neanche capaci a scrivere l'ha scritto
pure vale mi fa scassare veramente un
sacco la gente che disegna e poi che
dopo che rischiate una un ameba fa la
freccetta dalla serie questo è questo
cosa non si capisce niente
aridaje questa cosa la freccia ma cosa
vuol dire mi che vi fa scassare la
freccia cosa significa hai fatto un
disegno dal carico da par suo disegno
che faccio io disegno a casa facciamo
breccia cos'è fuori e ad se era for ed
era fronte ma non è la fronte go ed
indica la meglio
mio dio solo il ritornato solo io lo
stato bravissimo ma faccio una cagata
galassia l'allora galassia la galassia
bella allora tutto nero tutto nero tutto
nero ok
e poi questo aspetto è la più bella
galassia che vedrete in tutta la vostra
vita amici in realtà non dovrebbe sempre
questa la galassia però vabbè chi se ne
frega più o meno non me la cavo molto
bene coi corpi celesti però va beh più o
meno fare un po'di era difficile fare
garcia era difficile uno è uscito perché
l'ho fatto talmente male che è uscito by
bts famiglie cosi fare questo ma disegna
benissimo squid sale dio acqua
salt water acqua salata mio dio era
veramente difficile strangolamento
strangola me in spazio vitale
bene fa e iodio e io non ho capito che
cosa ha scritto ragazzi all assalto solo
perché l'ha scritto se non avrei mai
saputo scriverlo vabbè ilike maledizione
perché dovunque vg nocecchia hip hop
vabbè signori questa è la mia partita su
sky bellio è stato carino per quello che
è durato riuscito a fare le cose molto
decenti molto di pi di quanto sperassi
non nostro arrivato primo segreto
secondo però il secondo in alta sarebbe
il vero primo perché è al centro quindi
molto meglio spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come si deve più ci lasciano
quanto mi piace non so dirvi quando
diventerò bravo a disegnare per ogni mi
piace che mettete un punto schilly in
più per me nel disegno michelangelo
aveva un sacco di punti skill presto vi
sia piaciuto da ragazzi
[Musica]